calls for changes to sri lanka's
prevention of terrorism act grew louder
as hijaz hizbullah was released on bail
on tuesday the human rights lawyer spent
almost two years in detention because of
allegations that kept changing and i'm
looking forward to spending time with my
family two years i've been in custody
that's it thank you thank you everybody
police arrested him under anti-terrorism
legislation and accused the muslim
lawyer of involvement in the 2019 easter
bombings which killed 269 people
he was indicted 10 months later on
charges of fostering hate speech and
communal disharmony for a lecture at
this madrasa hezbollah denied the
charges
critics say the pta legislation is an
affront to the rule of law allowing
confessions in cases which they say
makes torture common
as well as lengthy detention sometimes
without judicial supervision pta has in
this case emblematically has been used
to stifle
individual liberties
very basically but he's like you know
access to lawyers being produced before
magistrate
asking for bail on knowing what your
charge is
on thursday the government tabled a bill
in parliament amending the pta
legislation
foreign minister gl perez says the
substantial changes to the existing laws
are progressive
opposition mps pointed out that the
european union has expressed
reservations about the proposed law
the eu sri lanka joint commission which
discusses common concerns says
the eu noted that important elements had
not been included in the amendment bill
gated
any citizen of this country can
challenge it in the supreme court
we have to avoid the determination of
the supreme court thereafter there will
be a full debate
here in parliament that is the proper
occasion for any views for and against
the amendment
opponents say the changes are cosmetic
and don't address the root of the
problem the pta or whatever the
legislation is with regard to terrorism
it's not about
isolating and protecting the state
the state is about its civilians
it is about our welfare at the end of
the day sri lanka's prevention of
terrorism act was introduced as
temporary legislation 43 years ago
but critics say it's become a weapon of
successive governments to stifle
opposition and descent linear fernandez
al jazeera colombo